good morning Hank it's Friday August
29th and since I know you don't like to
watch the news I'm now going to tell you
everything that I think you need to know
about presumptive Republican
vice-presidential nominee Sarah Palin
Palin I don't even want to say her name
I'm so surprised
part-1 Sarah Palin is the
forty-four-year-old governor of the
great state of Alaska she's been the
governor of Alaska for just under two
years before that she was the head of
the City Council in Wasilla Alaska but
Town name I might be mispronouncing even
though I've been there several times
number two on all of the social issues
that are important to the Republican
base she is reliably conservative she
strongly pro-life anti gay marriage and
a lifelong member of the National Rifle
Association in fact she is a moose
hunter that sounds like a euphemism for
something but it's not she actually
hunts moose number three in what might
be the most politically corrupt state in
the u.s. she has a reputation for being
strongly anti corruption Hank I briefly
lived in Alaska and let me tell you from
experience Alaska has about as many
uncorrupt politicians as it has pleasant
winter days so that's certainly a vote
in her favor another vote in her favor
would be thing for she's married to a
commercial fisherman now Hank I wasn't
able to find any pictures of Sarah
Palin's husband on the internet but I'm
hoping that he looks like the sailor
from The Simpsons
thing 5 she has a kid named track that's
a political liability who's joined the
army and going to Iraq that's a
political asset
it's like McCain was saying Joe Biden I
see your son who's going to Iraq and I
raise you an Alaskan infantryman name
track oh also I forgot to mention Sarah
Palin's husband is a semi-professional
snowmobiler really you raised in
snowmobiles Bing six she has absolutely
no foreign policy experience now of
course the McCain camp say that it
doesn't matter that she doesn't have
foreign policy experience because McCain
has loads of foreign policy experience
which is fine just so long as McCain is
you know alive which I thought was kind
of why you picked a vice president but
anyway things seven she's been a very
Alaska centric governor you know there
are some governor's like say Kathleen
Sebelius or Rob Blagojevich who end up
kind of leading on certain national
issues she hasn't been like that she's
all
Laska all the time I mean you could
argue that her energy policy has been
influential outside of Alaska in some
ways but I'm not convinced although she
is very popular in Alaska nerdfighters
particularly Republican nerdfighters I'm
interested to know what you think about
the Palin pick let me know in comments
hank don't forget to be awesome
and as always best wishes
oh and Hank the nerdfighters finished
the second part of the scavenger hunt I
already did one live vlog TV show but
I'm going to do another one today at
3:30 p.m. Eastern link in the sidebar